monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice un nom
ronflant mais surprenant le visage
d'eric dupond-moretti n'est pas inconnu
du grand public associés à une multitude
d'affaires médiatique cette figure
célèbre de la justice française manie
l'art du contre-pied tour à tour
défenseur du couple balkany bernard
tapie jérôme kerviel ou encore des
sportifs nikola karabatic et karim
benzema
celui que l'on surnomme acquittator est
plutôt du genre à aller à contre-courant
de l'opinion majoritaire ce sobriquet il
le doit à un palmarès fourni en
acquittements obtenus pour ses clients
plus de 150 au total la nomination du
successeur de nicole belloubet a de quoi
surprendre quand il entretient des
rapports tourmentée avec les
institutions fin juin dupond moretti
dépose plainte contre x
mécontent d'avoir été mis sous
surveillance par le parquet national
financier une plainte désormais retiré
annonce l'elysée sa nomination à la
justice suscite des réactions pour le
moins mitigé nommer une personnalité
aussi clivante et qui méprise à ce point
les magistrats c'est une déclaration de
guerre à la magistrature
quel est le message qu'entend plus le
ministre de la justice se trouve relégué
aussi loin dans l'ordre protocolaire le
mépris le plus total pour la justice
pour moraliser l'action politique lutter
contre le terrorisme et restaurer la
confiance de la police emmanuel macron
nomme ministre de la justice l'avocat
d'abdelkader meira ainsi que de
messieurs balkany et cahuzac
rappelons qu'un avocat peut toujours
choisir ses clients un gouvernement
libéral banal castaner belloubet honte
de l'intérieur de la justice enfin
démissionner darmanin dupond-moretti
doivent rétablir la dignité et l'honneur
félicitations à notre confrère eric
dupond-moretti dont l'engagement dans la
profession n'est plus à démontrer
gageons que les avocats et la justice
retrouveront avec lui la place centrale
qu'ils doivent avoir dans notre
démocratie et notre état de droit
récemment interrogé sur ce qu'il ferait
s'il devenait garde des sceaux dupond
moretti avait déjà quelques idées
concrètes
d'abord il faut qu'on sépare le siège du
parquet pour moi c'est impératif
je fais le ménage là-dedans de façon
très très très clair je fais un système
de responsabilité des juges parce que
les juges ne sont pas responsables de ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui ce sont les
seuls dans notre société ne pas être
responsable il faut réunir des juges et
faire une réforme non pas contre eux
mais avec eux avec des grands juges qui
font l'unanimité parmi les dossiers
brûlants prévu à son nouvel agenda la
colère des robes noires vis-à-vis de la
réforme des retraites ou encore le
nouveau code pénal pour mineurs initiée
par sa prédécesseure